von
Ich brauche ein paar Leute, die mitspielen, weil ansonsten wären wir wieder von irgendwelchen
komischen Wallhackern und sonst was direkt geohnt.
Ähm, ja gut, wenn du es nicht installiert hast, wird es schwierig.
Stripes, moin, willst du mitspielen?
Also ein paar Leute brauche ich noch hier.
Passion, Alter, Passion.
Also wer mitspielen will, am besten schon einen, den ich geeditert habe, wäre ganz
praktisch.
Ein bisschen Boomer Games spielen hier.
Jo, na dann, dann suche ich mal einen Server raus, nee, Moment, wie funktioniert das jetzt
nochmal?
Battlefield 3, Leute adden.
Achso, ja dann warte ich mal bis du online bist, irgendwo hier kann man Leute adden dann,
ne?
Ja.
Wie auch immer das genau funktioniert hat, das weiß ich nicht, das kriegen wir aber
gleich raus.
Das kriegen wir gleich raus.
Excellent, aber du hast jetzt den goldenen Keks hier, zum ersten Mal, huge, massive Keks.
Du hast mich nicht auf Origin, du musst mich doch auf Origin haben, hä?
Wenn nicht, schick mir einfach eine Anfrage und ich adde dich, hab die echt nicht auf
Origin?
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Hätte ich keinen Mr.
Army hier?
Nee.
Sieht nicht so aus.
Wahnsinn.
Kannst dir ja eine Anfrage schicken, dann adde ich dich, ganz unten in den Requests.
Ah, da ist er, exellent, exellent.
Willst du mal auf eine richtig kaputte Webseite gehen?
Nee, das ist bestimmt irgendwelche Torzgeschichten, da will ich nicht drauf, da will ich nicht
drauf.
Ach komm mal, er ist auch am Start.
Ja, kann man auch adden, klar.
Wie macht man denn hier noch mal ein Squad?
Wie hat denn das noch mal funktioniert?
Ich check's, ich check's, ne, warte mal, wie ging das hier noch mal?
Add, oft, nee.
Create Chat.
Jaja.
Chat, wie hat denn das noch mal funktioniert?
Wie hat man hier noch mal Squads gemacht?
Hier drüber irgendwie?
Create Chat?
Nein, ich bin nicht im Discord, ich hab Streamer, lul.
Kann man sich irgendwie...
Leg grad, wie das funktioniert.
Wo haben wir Mr.
Jacks nicht, wie hat man hier noch mal, wie hat man hier noch mal, doch online.
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, wie das funktioniert, wie man hier Squads macht.
Musste man überhaupt nen Chat createn?
Nee, oder?
Ich glaub, man musste da gar keinen Chat createn.
Aber ich bin Battlelog jetzt echt hier irgendwie drüber?
Also ihr seht, es ist ein Monat her, dass ich gespielt hab, ne?
Create a match?
Was?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, lul.
Das war Create Chat, ne?
Select.
Wo ist denn dann Mr.
Ami?
Seh ich den nicht?
Warum ist der hier nicht drinnen?
Die Hälfte, die hat doch die Hälfte wieder nicht geladen.
Ne, Platoon sind Clans quasi, sowas wie, ne.
Ich bin da zu dumm für F5en.
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, wie der Campel funktioniert.
Aber ich stell mich einfach mal auf Abwesen oder so, dann sieht man, was Sache ist und
man kann nachjoinen.
Kein Schimmer mehr, wie das funktioniert.
Stripes, hab ich dich im Origin drinnen?
Stripes, da isser.
Stripes, da isser, guck hier.
Und wenn man hier Leute edit, dann joint man zusammen, oder wie ist das?
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, wirklich nicht mehr, das ist komplett random.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie das funktioniert.
Leute, wir haben das doch auch schon mal geschafft.
Wir haben auch schon mal hier Battlefield zusammen gespielt, weiß gar nicht mal, wie
wir das gemacht haben.
Keine Ahnung.
So, äh, gut, gehen wir hier drauf, was anderes gibt's ja, äh, Kark Island, Conquest Lodge,
gibt's da nicht irgendwas ordentliches?
Rushed Classics, ok, Rushed Classics klingt doch schon mal ganz brauchbar.
Q Nummer 3, perfekt.
Leute, ihr könnt einfach über Origin gleich nachjoinen bei mir.
Mr.
Kark Island und Stripes, joint einfach nach, oder sagt mir mal, ob's funktioniert.
Wenn nicht, mach ich hier nochmal nen Chat auf.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wie der Kram funktioniert hat.
Ach guck mal, der joint ja auch schon, pock.
So, wie gesagt Leute, ich hab nen Monat oder so nicht mal gespielt, bin wahrscheinlich
richtig schlecht.
Sacke.
Zumindest ein Vorteil hat, dass das Game läuft, das Game läuft halt erst mal ordentlich mit,
äh, nee, wie war das, Perf, nee, Draw, oh, wie war das in, nee, das war nicht Perf Overlay,
äh, BF3, Draw FPS, Sac, wie war das in BF3 nochmal?
Render, Draw FPS, Render.
Render, Draw, FPS, 1, bam, jawoll, Bastion, Alter, Bastion, wie jetzt, oh, bisschen lauter,
wobei, ich glaube, Lautstärke ist durchaus in Ordnung, oder?
Lautstärke geht sogar halbwegs, klar.
So Leute, guck mal, ob du das mit dem nachjoinen findest.
Boah, ich bin, Alter, ich bin es ja überhaupt nicht mehr gewöhnt hier, an was sterben die
denn bitteschön hier?
Gar nicht, Rättsstellts, ja, Captain Pongas, join mal rein, lass mal gucken, ob's, oh,
okay, ich hab absolut keinen Plan mehr, oh, nice hier, huge Rats, fuck, alles klar, geht
ja gut los.
Ich glaub, die überrennen uns ganz schön, guck mal, der erst 23.6, jetzt schon, ich
mein, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht spielt der ja Heli und geht voll ab oder Amtrak oder
sonst was, das ist ja immer noch möglich.
Alter, oh Gott, wie ist denn meine Maus hier eingestellt?
Alter, MonkaS, Captain Pongas ist am Start, aber nicht bei mir, sondern dem anderen Team,
okay, ich glaube, man konnte hier gar nicht mit Squad zu richtig joinen, sag mal, leck
das wie Sau, kann das sein?
Wo ist denn hier mein, ne, äh, Captain Pongas, du bist bei den Attackern, vielleicht kannst
du switchen, ansonsten versuch ich mal zu switchen, man muss einfach auf die gleiche
Seite, Leute, man braucht ja gar keinen Squad aufmachen hier auch, ich kann auch den Chat
und so wieder ausmachen, das braucht man ja gar nicht, Mister Ami ist am Start, nice,
das braucht man doch gar nicht, man muss einfach auf die gleiche Seite und dann kann man sagen,
man geht in D oder so, oh, es ist ungewohnt, es ist ungewohnt, dass man nicht mehr sliden
kann, kein Slider, war hier nicht ein M-Com? War hier nicht normalerweise ein M-Com? Ah
ne, hier ist das gewesen, lull, Alter, als hätt ich das Game noch nie gespielt, man,
okay, kein Plan, Leute, das dauert jetzt kurz, bis ich da wieder reingekommen bin, und man
muss ja auch wieder Q drücken, das hab ich auch ganz vergessen, man muss ja Q drücken
für Spot Action, okay, wir lernen Battlefield 3 neu, easy, konnte man da hinten rein, okay,
hier ist es, ah, meine Maus-Handsettings, lull, das muss ich irgendwie umstellen, Klei,
mal gucken, mal gucken, ob ich überhaupt Gegner treffe, okay, krasser, ah, Rüstungstelz,
nein, nein, nein, das war das Battlefield 3 Movement, das hat so seine Tücken, yup,
nice, also, wir sind Leute, wer bei uns in Squads will, wir sind Squad India, ich kann
Ich kann auch einfach ein Neues gleich aufmachen, wobei Mr. Army ist nicht mehr da.
Ist er...
Geh mal, da geh ich mal zu Fate rein, jetzt bin ich in Juliott.
Boah, die Oberrennern uns hier heftig.
Ich dachte, ich kann jetzt erst mal ein bisschen Noob-mäßig hier wieder einsteigen.
Aber das geht ja, kannst du ja komplett vergessen.
Punkbuster-Kick-Player? Seriously?
Warum das denn?
Ah, das musst du starten. Kann es sein, dass du das nicht gestartet hast im Service?
Man muss das ja im Service starten, dass das funktioniert.
Leute, hier ist...
Hier ist ja 64-Mann schon clusterfuck.
Wie hat man sich da gedacht, bei Battlefield 2042 ist es eine gute Idee...
Alter, es ist eine gute Idee, 128 Spieler zu nehmen.
Aber gut, ich werde gerätzt, ich bin ja...
Ich bin ja schon zufrieden.
Wir aimen das hier mal kurz ab.
Da stellt es gerne...
Sieht irgendjemand überhaupt die Gegner?
Äh, läuft das Stream flüssig?
Okay, alles klar.
Ach nee, Moment, man muss ja die ganze Zeit springen, dass man nicht mehr aufhört.
Ach nee, Moment, man muss ja die ganze Zeit springen, dass man schneller läuft.
Ich erinnere mich, Leute, ich erinnere mich.
Huge, I remember, I remember.
Punkbuster A und B laufen, ja dann ist es komisch.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich wusste, dass da einer steht.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung wo, aber...
Oh, da vorne irgendwo.
Rein, rein stellst du, rechts, rechts ist er.
Irgendwo, irgendwo hier.
Wo zum Geier kamen die denn jetzt her?
Sind die, sind die parachuted hinter mir oder so?
Boah, wir müssen irgendwas anderes spielen als 64 Spieler.
Das überfordert mich jetzt.
Boomer hier, erstmal.
Wenn ich das so lange nicht gespielt habe, ich brauchte immer ein bisschen, bis ich wieder reinkomme.
Okay.
Attack.
Oh oh, oh oh.
Nice, next.
Wo ist das Auto?
Weiß ich was.
Aber der Stream lag nicht, oder?
Der Stream, also Battlefield 3 braucht ja nichts an Leistung.
Der sollte ohne Probleme laufen hier.
Stream läuft gut, ok.
Nice, GG Eats.
Hier sind sie doch, hier.
Was? Alter, Battlefield Hit-Rag.
Battlefield Hit-Rag.
Keg Wayne.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Alter, Battlefield Hit-Rag. Lul, das ist ja schon der Wahnsinn.
Es ruckelt durch Explosionen, da kannst du nichts gegen machen.
Ich hab den Eindruck, ich muss ein bisschen hochstellen.
Ziemlich hinterher bin mit der Maus.
Aber gut, komm.
Wisst ihr was, Leute, ich hab so lange nicht gespielt.
Wir müssen, ich hab jetzt eine Ausrede für M16.
Siehste, wie schön das in Battlefield 3 war. Einfach ne Runde Defi-Spammen und schon easy.
War das der Gegner?
Einfach Defi-Spammen und schon stehen sie wieder alle.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber es geht.
Es geht, es geht, es geht.
Es geht, es geht.
Einfach Defi-Spammen und schon stehen sie wieder alle.
Keine zwei Stunden hoffen, dass sich Gegner nicht basht, während du wiederbelebst.
Okay, gib ihm, Leute, gib ihm.
Oh, ich hab rechts einen gesehen.
Bin mir nicht so sicher genau, was ich gehitted hab.
Alter, ich treff nix. Irgendwas stimmt meins. Oder ich bin Battlefield 2042 gewöhnt.
Lul, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich Battlefield 2042 gewöhnt.
Das ist vorbei. Da hat man sich dran gewöhnt, dass man nix trifft und dass man ein bisschen was trifft bei nix treffen und jetzt ist es vorbei.
Äh, hallo? Wo ist der?
Wo?
Cool.
Die schießen mich vom Dach an, oder?
Schießen die mich vom Dach an?
Bam, ba, ba, bam. Helibash.
Au. Keine gute, keine gute Sache.
In the Kopf. Nein, nein, nein. Kopf raus.
Kopf raus. Kopf raus. Jawoll. Sehr gut.
Oh. Ist das modded oder normale Version? Das ist die ganz normale Version.
Das ist die ganz normale Version, die man, die jeder spielen kann gerade.
Was hier? Was ist mit dem da los?
Was ist mit dem da los? Was ist mit dem da los?
Auf, auf.
Schön defien.
Über Bande.
Boah. Game. Hör auf zu ruckeln.
Das Game ist so krass am ruckeln. Du kannst ja nicht immer zielen.
Hier auf irgendwas. Lebt der noch auf dem Dach? Oder nicht? Oder?
Die Konfig Option zum Abschalten des Geruckels.
Moment, da unten ist was.
Wo, wo, wo?
Erst mal hinlegen.
Y ist es. Ich denke mir schon irgendwie, ich drücke zwar Y automatisch.
Aber mir war gar nicht klar, weil ich für ein Getaste gerade drücke.
Okay, nächste Runde jetzt mal gucken, ob das jetzt ein bisschen kontrollierter
vonstatten geht.
Tja, ich hatte die Auswahl heute.
Ähm, guck ich mir den neuen Patch Battlefield 2042 an.
Leute, es gibt ein Scoreboard. Ja, stellt euch mal vor. Guckt mal, guckt mal.
Seht ihr das?
Ein Scoreboard.
Das ist unglaublich.
Hexen wird es.
Das ist unglaublich. Hexenwerk, dass es sowas überhaupt gibt.
Ich meine, es gibt schon keinen Chat am Ende der Runde.
Das haben sie ja schon, haben sie ja schon weggelassen, weil Ende der Runde immer,
immer krass geflamet wird.
Nose, Hair, Candles, jetzt Attacker.
Auf, pass auf Leute, jetzt geht es, jetzt geht es drüber. Jetzt wird drüber geschlittert.
Chat, konntest du einstellen? Nee.
Chat, konntest du nicht einstellen Ende der Runde? Oder ist das was Neues, was mir noch nichts sagt?
Ende der Runde, Chat? Ich meine, du kannst hier Chat machen so.
Peck, Wait, konntest du machen.
Aber Ende der Runde, Chat? Wie hat man das, und wie soll das gehen?
Du musst den Punkbuster-Service neu starten.
Du musst den Punkbuster-Service neu starten, also starten in den Services von Windows,
dann funktioniert das.
So, hau, ah, Granate, damn, das war klar, komm ich hol dich, Kollege, müssen wir mal
gucken.
Boah, nein, ja was, huge suppression, Poggers, Poggers suppression, so, tja, M16 würde ich
dazu sagen, M16, M16.
Alles klar, M16, was mit H ging das noch, während das Spiel läuft, kann ich mich jetzt
nicht dran erinnern.
I don't know, so, bashen, wo sind's, ah, stuck, bitte random step bro, I'm stuck,
Joke einsetzen, oh, ich dachte das geht, wenn ich einfach nur drauf spray aus der Hüfte.
Nur plus, während am Ende nicht mehr, ok, ein Prozent, wollen die mich veräbbeln.
Wünsche für das nächste Battlefield, hey, was heißt das nächste Battlefield, das nächste
Battlefield kam vor zwei Monaten raus und es hat leider gesagt, ich muss mich
an das Q drücken gewöhnen. Ich drück kaum Q Leute. Geht das noch jemand so?
Ganz schlechte Idee. Geht das noch jemand so, der vorher 2042 gespielt hat,
dass man sich abgewöhnt hat Q zu drücken. So krass, ich bin es null gewöhnt Q zu drücken.
Geh basten, jetzt hier basten. Jetzt gehts rein. Da ist der nächste. Weggesprayt. Aber guck mal
hier, beste Squad Leute, beste Squad, easy win. Danke schön für den Sub. Was spielen wir denn?
Sand Crossing. Sand Crossing ist Pog. Die Legehänne ist am Start Leute. Doppel, Dual,
Multithreaded Legehänne. Okay, nice. Multithreaded Legehänne war am Start.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken. Jetzt kommen wir da rüber. Bashen, alter, bashen. Okay, nice. Wir
haben einen Smokeman am Start. Beste, easy win. Oh oh. Legehänne. Pog. Hast du noch Kontakt zum
Kaboom? Selten, selten. Aber Granatenspam. Genau, einfach Granatenspam drauf. Easy win. Oh nee,
die haben diffused. Haben die? Anzeige ist raus. Warum diffusen die einfach? By the way,
diese MGs an den Booten und den Panzern, diese stationären Dinger, die waren so schlecht,
krass. Krass hier. Wo? Da. In der Treppe war der drinne gestucked. Wir könnten noch
mehr Suppression vertragen. War Anti-Suppression nicht verbackt? War das nicht irgendwie verbackt
Anti-Suppression? War da nicht was? Ich erinnere mich irgendwie, ich dachte Anti-Suppression ist
irgendwie verbackt. So seit 10 Jahren. Fuck. Okay, jetzt nochmal durchzukommen ist schwierig.
Auf, streck deinen Kopf raus. In the ass. I get fucked up in the ass over here. Ich
campere mal kurz hier eine Runde. Mir bleibt gerade nichts anderes übrig. Von hinten kommt
was Leute. Von hinten kommt was. Die wollen mich bashen, Alter. Ich sehe es schon kaum
hier. Da sind doch noch mehr hier. Jetzt flankt einer rum. Ja klar. Nice, nice, nice. An der
Seite, hä? Okay, jetzt kommen wir ein Stückchen vor. Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal. Ja, please,
Battlefield. Hallo, ich möchte einfach nur drüberspringen. Wenn es im Bereich des Möglichen
ist. Ich habe Schiss, Leute. Ich verpiss mich. Oh, oh, oh.
Wo ist er? Keiner da. Auf jetzt, lege Hände hier. Lege Hände in Action. Ach, wir haben
es schon. Hä? Leute, what the? Wann haben wir das gelegt? Wait, Kek. Kek, wait. Ich
dachte, ich dachte, ich muss hier noch krasse Stells Action machen. Wann haben wir das geholt?
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt? Wann haben wir denn, wann haben wir das M-Kong erwischt? Okay,
ich will mich ja nicht beschweren. Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung. Hier ist noch irgendwo
was drüben. Muss ich mal kurz ein Stückchen verpissen. Da wird reingedroppt. Okay, A sollten
wir eigentlich mit dem M-Track kriegen. Eins merkt man, Leute, die, äh, wie soll man so
sagen? Die Abtastrate auf dem Server ist halt wirklich krottig. Das Witzige ist, die ist
ja potenziell in Battlefield 2042 besser, aber in Battlefield 2042 registrieren die
Schüsse halt einfach nicht. Oh, oh, Monkeys. Boah, Alter, wie viele Granaten, Mann. Mr.
Army auch und wieder alles hier. Nice, TRX. Leute. Oh, oh, oh. Guck mal, hier sind so viele
Leichen. Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen weiter hinter. Ich glaube, boah, wenn wir hier, wenn
wir hier, auf der, auf der Seite kommen wir nicht durch. Hier, nice, nice, nice, nice,
nice. Lege Hände, lege Hände, lege Hände. Ich setze mich jetzt da rein. Das hast du
jetzt, oh nee, fuck. Ich wollte gerade switchen auf die Magnum. Leute, rein da. Jetzt wird
gesprägt. So eine Action hast du in Battlefield 2042 nicht. Welchen Server? Ach, keine Ahnung,
der erste, beste, den du angezeigt kriegst bei Rush. Sag mal, da krabbelt noch einer
da oben. Krasser Krabbelhaus. Boister Krabbelhaus. Nice Krabbelhaus, guckt euch mal. Guck mal,
seht ihr das? Seht ihr das? Wie geil die Leute hier aufs Rassen und Punktefarmen sind. Konnte
man eins? Nein, konnte man nicht. Ja, 64 Spieler Rush, das ist, das ist schon, ist schon knapp
am Clusterfuck. Au, au, nein, nein, nein. Wo, wo? Streck deinen Kopf raus. Ach da, jetzt
hätte ich mal ein bisschen Burst schießen sollen. Aber das Gute ist, M16, wozu brauchst
du Burst? Blank Action hier, flankerino, massive flank. Irgendwo hier unten war doch gerade
einer, oder? Oder wurde das auf der Map? Alter, die krassen Sneaky Leute, guckt sie euch
an. Einfach da in der Ecke hat er gelegen, einfach in der Ecke. Engstellt, hoch 10.
Auf, auf, beeil dich, beeil dich, mann, beeil dich. Ey, das ist ja Battlefield 2042 Hit-Rack.
Habt ihr das gesehen? Alter, Battlefield, das war richtig krass, Battlefield 2042 Hit-Rack.
Wird Bad Company 2 noch gespielt? Ja, aber deutlich weniger. Ja, leider hat Venice den
Hype nicht geschafft, ja. Das lag, da waren die aber mit, mit selbst dran schuld. Die
hätten zum Beispiel Surfer anbieten müssen von ihnen. Anders funktioniert das nicht,
mit, mit gutem Rules. Alter, von, von wo? Ach, von der Straße aus. Aber Battlefield
3 Kreise laufen geht eigentlich immer. Oh, nice, huge risk. Alter. Okay, nice. Jetzt
kommt von da noch einer. Der hat sich jetzt auch gedacht, ich weiß nicht genau, was mir
passiert. Einfach gespornet und den Arsch mit der Magne umgeshootet bekommen. Oh, das
fetzt hier richtig rein wieder. Au, au, au, au. Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, von wo? Shit,
shit, shit, shit, shit. Von wo, von wo, von wo? Ach, von der Anti-Air. Shit, die hab
ich ja gar nicht gedacht. Okay, auf gehts. So, verstecken, erst, erst mal, erst mal ver...
Verstecken im Busch. Verstecken im Busch, das geht eigentlich immer. Busch, Busch stellt,
das ist da unten. Null. Ja, ja, ist da gut, reg nicht mal ab. So, next, next. Oh, das
wird, das wird jetzt was hier durchzukommen. Oh, von rechts, von rechts, von rechts. Ich
renn einfach mal rum und retze ein bisschen. Alter, die sind hinter uns. Oh, shit. Ich
seh gar nix. Wo ist denn hier was? Leute, ich hab legit keine Ahnung, wo hier irgendwas
geht gerade. Okay. Nein? Ah, da. Ach, da. Obvious, obvious. Das reviven war so OP. Naja,
aber das hat dazu geführt, ja, das war schon OP, aber das hat dazu geführt, dass die Leute
das wenigstens machen. Nieseln wie in Battlefield 2041. Wir wollen Zen Crossing spielen. So,
Yolo, Yolo Res. Alter, rein da, rein da, Leute, es muss klatschen. Bam, bababam. Granatenspam
aufs M kommen. Macht sie platt. Oh, nice, huge res. Ah, mehr res, res drain am Start.
Fuck man, Alter. Das war nicht normal. Guckt euch, ach du Scheiße. Boah, und von der Seite
weggerotzt. Richtig Gatchi-Buzz. Das ist richtig Gatchi-Buzz hier gerade. Okay, ich rede wieder
wie ihres Zeug, aber Alter, ich krieg hier mal. Übrigens, das reviven, dass das nicht
als Tod zählt, finde ich auch sehr, sehr nice. Das ist auch wieder ein Anreiz, ja.
Ich mein, das ist doch das Optimale aus beiden Welten. Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, wo der
Pizzen ist. Die Leute behalten ihre Kills und die Leute verlieren ihre Deaths. Das ist
im Prinzip alle glücklich gemacht. Ich laufe übrigens die ganze Zeit im Kreis, weil ich
nicht weiß, wo ich hin soll. Gatchirole. Ich Gatchirole. Alter. Aber fuck, ich hab
keine Ahnung. Aber fünf. Ich will Sandcrossing spielen. Oder wie wir früher gesagt haben,
ahnungslos seine Crossing. Seine Crossing. Leute, was? Seid ihr Sandcrossing-Spieler oder
seine Crossing-Enjoyer? Sandcrossing. Sandcrossing, ja. Die Aussprache gab es auch noch. Sandcrossing.
Ich muss mehr Q drücken, Leute. Ich drücke überhaupt keinen Q. Guck mal hier. Hätte
ich mehr Q gedrückt, hätt ich gleich gewusst, dass ich hier durch den Smoke Leute sprayen
kann. Einfach durch den Smoke sprayen. Oh, da hinten ist was los. Da hinten ist Gatchirole
in der Ecke. Ich hab's genau gesehen. Ich Gatchirole. Seht ihr den? Jetzt so Webster
aufs Dach. Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice. Aber da sieht man, dass
diese Specialist-Powers zwar vielleicht nicht ganz cool spaßig für den einzelnen Spielen,
aber halt für die Struktur der Map und so, dass normale Battlefield-Gampler halt gar
nicht mal so sinnig sind, ne? Alter, hier wird wiederbelebt. Hier wird wiederbelebt
auf Doom. Was? Wo ist der Typ? Oh, da ist noch mehr. Da hinten ist er. Da hinten ist
noch einer. Guck mal hier. Der Gatchi bastet uns von hinten. Das fand ich auch cool. Dieses
Springen und Rassen dabei. Bam, bap, bap, bam. So muss das sein. Oh, die sind eh immer
noch da. Ich wollte ein Messer. Kick, Wade. Hätte ja funktionieren können. Es hätte
ja klappen können. NA-Aim. Ja gut, das kann man jetzt von mir nicht anders erwarten als
37-jähriger Boomer. 37-jähriger Boomer, dafür geht es noch durchaus in Ordnung. Ja, das
waren halt typische Battlefield-Rasses. Mal geht's, mal geht's nicht. Die letzte Base
ist schwer. Pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt den Big Brain Play schlechthin. Ich zeige
euch mal den Massive. High IQ, only 150 IQ plus Play für die letzte Base. Pass mal auf,
werdet ihr gleich sehen. 6 head, 11, 25 head. Wo? Okay, only 5 heads, only 5 head plays.
Es geht aber nicht, weil die Leute im Stream gucken. Nein, wir wollen Sandcrossing spielen.
Wir sind Sandcrossing-Enjoyer. Oh ne, der hat mein 5-Head-Plan zunichte gemacht, weil
er mit dem Schiff langgefahren ist. Der Bender-Bubber. Der eigentliche 11-Head-Play ist hier langschwimmen
und dann hinten rausstelzen am Wasser. Das geht natürlich nicht, wenn die Leute dort
mit dem Boot am Start sind. Okay, jetzt 6 head, 6 head. Only 6 head plays. Oh, da ist ein
Typ. Oh ne, das ist eine ganz schlechte Idee. Die Seite ist schon komplett voll. Jawoll,
jetzt sind sie abgelenkt. Nein, nein. Was bist du noch im Boot? Was bist du noch im
Boot? So sollst du gefälligstes M-Com diffusen. Anzeige ist raus. Nein, Battlefield, so ist
das nicht, wie der Fallschirm funktioniert. Ich glaube, das war Server-Lag, der uns gekillt
hat. Kann es sein, dass ich auf diesem komischen Mast gelandet bin? Alter, 50 Milliarden Gegner.
Muss er vielleicht 5 schreiben, anstatt Slash 5 zu machen? Ich glaube, das jebaitet uns
einfach nur zum sinnlos Reintroppen hier oben. Das hat, glaube ich, gar keinen sinnigen
Mehrwert hier. Wir sollten, glaube ich, lieber hinten spawnen. Ey du. Danke für die Subs,
ich kann gerade nicht gucken. Ich sehe nichts. Sixhead, Sixhead-Time, Leute, Sixhead-Time.
Wehe, du bist wieder in diesem komischen Schlauchboot drinne. Sixhead-Time. Die stehen da mit dem
Auto, ich fasse es nicht. Oh nee. Oh, in der S geschudelt, Mann. Krass, in der S geschudelt.
Okay, hier kannst du nichts machen. Okay, hier ist mit, oh mein Gott, hier ist mit viel
zu viel los. Aber das war erfolgreich. Nicht so sehr erfolgreich für das Mkomm. Ja, es
gibt noch, wenn es unleashed, aber die haben es leider ein wenig verkackt. Du entschärfst
es. Jawoll, komm, Mkomm. Praege, Praege, Praege. Jawoll, wir haben es, nice. Erfolgreich gepraegt.
Wegfahren, Alter. Okay, unser Amtrak ist down. Nein, unser Amtrak ist nicht down. Massive
Amtrak-Rap. Nee, das ist der Jeep. Alter, Boomer hier macht es nicht mehr mit, Leute,
es ist vorbei. Nee, jetzt, Venice hat keine Spieler mehr. Ja, ich gehe in unseren Amtrak,
damit ich den retten kann. Boah, hier ist ja so Action, Alter, das ist ja nicht normal.
The charge has been set, sehr gut. Gehen wir mal ran, wenn der Charge gesettet ist. Lass
mich rein. Aber wir könnten es durchaus kriegen, also wir drücken da gerade richtig, richtig
heftig rein. Gachi-Buzz. Alter, ich sehe nichts.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo hier was abgeht. Ja, wenn die Server abgeschaltet werden, dafür
ist Venice natürlich richtig nice. Wenn Server abgeschaltet wird, dann kann man mit Venice
halt noch weiterspielen. Das hat das Game auch wirklich verdient, also damit ist das
Game ja quasi unsterblich, wenn man es so will. Oh, das sind ganz schön viele Leute.
Oh, auch von hinten. Oh, oh, oh nee. Ich wusste nicht, ob ich auf 3 oder 4 mein RPG habe.
Wo habe ich mein RPG? 3 oder 4? Ich spiele es zu wenig. Ich spiele auch viel zu selten,
Engineer. Oh nee, jetzt ist er down. Jetzt ist der M-Track hinüber. Da machst du nichts
mehr. Es ist aber halt ziemlich kacke, hier rein zu kommen. Boah, vergiss es. Du kannst
dich in 64 Mann reintropfen. Nö, keine Chance. Das geht nicht, wir müssen das irgendwie
normal aufbauen. Das wird nicht, das baitet höchstens die Leute rein. Einmal weggeguckt,
direkt deadge. 64 Spieler Rush ist einfach zu viel. Ja, dann denkt man sich so, was haben
die sich bei DICE gedacht mit 128 Mann Breakthrough? Sollte ich euch sagen, was die sich dabei
gedacht haben? Nix. Nix haben die sich dabei gedacht. Gachibas haben die sich dabei gedacht.
Da kommt jetzt gleich noch mehr hier, Leute. Das hast du dir so gedacht. Ach, der Dude
lebt noch. Nein, ich hab die Taste gar nicht gedrückt. Leute, wir haben's nicht. Wir haben
es verloren. Alles draufschmeißen, Leute, alles draufschmeißen. Yes. Yes. Wir haben's,
wir haben's, oder? Haben wir's? Bam! In your face, nice. Alter Corona schlägt zu. Der
Server war überfordert. Warum war der Server überfordert? Es lief doch halbwegs flüssig.
Ach so, das meinst du Hittrack. Ja, das hatte ich zwischendurch auch. Die Musik im Hintergrund.
Was kommt denn als nächstes für eine Map? Ich hoffe Zen Crossing. Seine, seine Überquerung.
Dema wird Peacrush, auch gut. Sehr gut. Exquisite. Zen Crossing, Leute. Excellent, excellent.
Warum kann ich eigentlich keine Vollbild-Memes einblenden? Sag bloß ich spiele nicht im Fullscreen.
Alter, wer spielt denn bitteschön Fullscreen? Fullscreen? Nee, Moment. Konnte das Spiel
überhaupt borderless Fullscreen? Wait a minute, konnte das borderless Fullscreen? Okay, ich
spiele jetzt erstmal ne Runde. Team Switch please, Server erlaubt's nicht. Dann versuch
neu zu joinen, dann vielleicht. Wir sind eh total verteilt. So. Chat ist voll am Durchdrehen.
Konnte das kein borderless Fullscreen? Nee, jetzt ist Fullscreen off. Geht aber immer
noch nicht. Das lügt einfach nur. Fullscreen ist nicht off. Lügengame.
Nice spawn protection. Was, irgendjemand soll gebannt werden? Warum ist Hackerman am Start?
Oh nee, was ist hier los? Anzeige ist raus. Jaja, schön diffusen. Diffuse-Champ. Diffuse-Champ.
Was ist hier los? Warum aimt da mehr als einer auf die gleiche Person? Direkt blocken. Alles
bannt. Nein. Alter. Ich muss... Oost-Champ. Ai ai ai.
Richtig heftiger Hoost-Champ. Von wo? Von wo? Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung was mich hier
von wo hittet gerade. Um ehrlich zu sein. Aber irgendwas hittet mich von irgendwo. Ah
da oben ist ein Auto. Moment mal ein BBBBBB. Von oben? Nee.
Okay, hier ist aber gerade ziemlicher Druck drauf. Leute, ich spotte immer noch nicht.
Ich hab's mir mit 2042 abgewöhnt zu spotten. Und dabei ist das hier das OPste was man machen
kann ordentlich spotten. Nein, nein, nein. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. So, erst mal
kurz ausruhen. Just, ja, just cool. Der kommt doch jetzt hier rum gleich der Kerl.
Okay, das Problem an der ersten Base Demavent Peak ist, die artet halt auch relativ schnell
in Spawn-Rape aus, wenn man mal die Gegner ordentlich zurückgepusht hat. Hallo, Game.
Nice. Hätte das mal schneller funktioniert. Du hast damals angefangen mit Battlefield
3, Atlon 2, GeForce GT 520, 30 FPS, Enjoyer. Hört sich zumindest so an. Auf der Xbox lief
das ja noch nicht mal mit, also auf der Xbox lief das weder mit 720p noch mit konstanten
30 FPS. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, wie ich den Krempel damals überhaupt spielen
konnte, realistisch betrachtet, aber tja, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, aus irgendwelchen
Gründen fand ich das Game trotzdem geil, obwohl ich quasi keine FPS hatte und keine
ordentliche Auflösung und nix. Das Gute ist, dass man nicht so einfach zu hitten ist, wenn
man die ganze Zeit über so Zeug drüberspringt. Ja, 64 Spawn Rush ist zu viel. Ich guck da
nach auch mal nach einem anderen Surfer, aber ein paar Runden spielen wir noch mal, wir
haben ja Zeit. Wo ist er? Wo ist er? Alter, geh fort. Oh ne, so wenn ich hier zu lang
rausgucke ist direkt, wirste, wenn ich hier einmal zu lang Peaks bitte. Alter, wie kommst
du her? Wo, wo, da ist er einfach bei uns in der Base. Backrage. Gatschi-Buzz. Ok, das
war eine dumme Idee hier rauszustellen. Das ist wieder so eine dumme Demavent Peak Runde,
das artet schon in halbem Spawn Rape aus der Attacker, aber noch geht's, noch ist es halbwegs
im Rahmen. Also die kommen ja immer noch rangepusht und alles. Ach, da oben sind sie. Warte, wir
haben die erst jetzt geschafft. Glaubste, ich glaub's ja nicht. So, ich bleib hier.
Wenn wir jetzt alle rüberrennen zu B, man denkt ja immer nur man ist der einzige, der
es selbst reißen kann, ne, aber wenn man alle rüberrennt, dann sind sie halt easy durchgepusht.
Weißt du, dabei geht's auch ohne Probleme so. Konnte man hier nicht irgendwie sogar
raus? Ich glaube, ich glaube, das testen wir jetzt mal, ich glaube, das ging. Spawn Bash
Enjoyer. Aber so sollte man das eigentlich nicht machen, weil dann ist ganz schnell Ragequit
angesagt bei den Attackern. Fuck, es ist abgelaufen.
Ja, das ist das Dumme an der ersten Base von Demavent Peak. Das ist richtig blöde.
Oh, jetzt pushen sie. Jetzt pushen sie aber gut hier. Gatschi push. Was war das? Schneiberman
hat mir den Fuß geschneibt. Okay, ich glaube, wir haben es abgewehrt. Pass auf, wenn das
jetzt hittet, dann muss ich aber kecken. Aber geiert das halbe Gegner-Team hier nur, na gut,
nein, die geiern auf alle. Das ist halt das Problem des Attacker-Team, dass, da ist noch
einer. Das Attacker-Team ist halt, hat zu viel Schiss. Oh Mist, das war stumpf. Das Attacker-Team
hat halt zu viel Schiss. Wie? Das ist mein Team hier? Lul. Und jetzt können wir sie
abfacken, Leute. Jetzt können wir sie richtig abfacken. Wir klauen uns ihren Jeep. Jetzt
können wir sie richtig abfacken, Leute. Ich sag's euch. Fuck. Einfach hier mit dem Jeep
stehen bleiben. Jetzt können sie nicht mal mit dem Jeep spawnen. Guck mal, wie es einschlägt
die ganze Zeit. Aber die Runde ist ja gleich vorbei. Alter, der Bender-Baba will es aber
echt wissen mit seinem Schneiberzeug. Lass mal auf einen leeren 32-Mann-Säuber gehen.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Aber erstmal will ich gucken, was nach dieser Runde kommt. Oh.
Jetzt mal gucken, was nach dieser Runde kommt. Wenn da nämlich ZenCross hin kommt, dann
spielen wir die noch. Ansonsten machen wir den Server voll mit dem cutesten Chat auf
Twitch. Nach dieser Runde kommt Attacker-Rückrunde. Ja gut. Denn wir rutschen mal schnell drüber.
Hoff ich mal. Sag mal, hat der Mörser-Kerl nichts besseres zu tun, als einfach nur auf
mich seine komischen Mörser am Arsch der Welt abzuballern? Im Prinzip ist es, Leute,
dass es eh nur noch aussitzen jetzt. Sagt mal, läuft das Spiel, kann das Spiel nicht
mit Fullscreen off? Nee, nee, nee, nee. Das geht, glaube ich, nicht. Ich glaube, das
hatte kein Borderless-Fullscreen, oder? Ich glaube echt, das hatte kein Borderless-Fullscreen.
Weil es ist dumm, wenn das kein Borderless-Fullscreen hat, dann kann ich gar nicht irgendwelche
sinnlosen Sachen einplanten oder so. Und das ist ja unglaublich wichtig, wie wir alle
wissen. Oh, was ist hier los? Lul, das war ein Hit. Das war angeblich ein Hit. Ja, ich
meine Borderless-Window, genau. Borderless-Window meine ich. Das soll ein Hit gewesen sein
gerade. Ich habe irgendwo einfach random in die Luft gesprayt und er ist gestorben.
Ich meine, ich habe schon in die Richtung geschossen, aber ich war garantiert nicht
drauf. Hacker-Man. Hacks activated. 25 Jahre altes Game. Okay, nicht wirklich ganz. Wie
alt ist es jetzt? 11 Jahre? 11 Jahre, ich glaube 11 Jahre, oder? Game, please, come on.
Ja, ja. Oh, ich habe es nicht mehr raus geschafft.
Grün gleich FPS, ja, korrekt. 10 Jahre alt, 10 Jahre alt. Grün in das Game frisst ja
nichts. Ich glaube, mehr als 200 FPS kann man gar nicht haben in Battlefield 3. Ich
meine, ich habe einen 240-Hertz-Monitor und ich habe V-Sync aus, also insofern, ich glaube,
mehr geht nicht. Ohne Scheiß, Leute. So ultra viel schlechter
als 2042 sieht das jetzt auch nicht aus. Von der Performance her halt ganz zu schweigen.
Aber 2042 hat halt die deutlich neuere Engine und könnte sicherlich, wenn die sich Mühe
gegeben hätten, die Karten detailliert und schön zu machen, deutlich besser aussehen.
Ich meine, guckt euch Battlefield 5 an. Battlefield 5 war wirklich und auch Battlefield 1, aber
gerade Battlefield 5 hatte schon sehr hübsche Szenerie, sehr hübsche Maps und Hintergründe
und Details und so. Das war schon nice. Battlefield 5 sieht schon viel, viel cooler aus als Battlefield
3, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als wären da irgendwie Welten dazwischen.
Das Problem ist, dass es kacke aussieht, weil es halt keine Details hat und die keine
Mühe reingesteckt haben. Okay, die Runde war jetzt nicht sonderlich
spannend. Defense, erste Base, easy win. Nice. Ich würde sagen, GG Eats, auf geht's.
Laschen, direkt ins Auto rein, direkt ins Auto rein, Leute. Kommt her, volle Pulle. Ich fahre
euch in die Base und ihr macht Gatschi-Buzz mit den Gegnern. Die Pro-Route, Leute.
Nein, nein, nein. Vor uns, vor uns, vor uns. Ich habe mich überfahren, aber die Leute
sind zum Glück ausgestiegen. Der Schneiber-Typ, erstmal richtig drübergerollt.
Wie gut auch der Sound ist. Da kommt was, da kommt was, Leute. Wie gut auch einfach der
Sound ist in dem Game. Oh, Gatschi-Buzz, Gatschi-Buzz. Nein, zu spät. Und es hatte tatsächlich
einen ganz guten Singleplayer. Ich meine, der Singleplayer ist jetzt nichts, wo ich
sagen würde, er hat, denke ich, in 100 Jahren noch dran jetzt übertrieben gesagt, aber
es ist durchaus in Ordnung gewesen, der Singleplayer. Ich finde, von allen Battlefield-Singleplayer
hatte der die beste, die beste Story immerhin. Sag mal. Wow, da habe ich nämlich gerechnet,
so viele hier drum rumstehen. Die Jett-Mission war richtig nice, von der Optik her. Vom Gameplay
her war die Jett-Mission pepega. Ich aim jetzt einfach die Ecke ab, bis da einer rauskommt.
Ich kann nicht raus. Okay. Ich habe unten links jetzt auf mein Team geguckt, wo einer
vorbeigelaufen ist. Okay, pass mal auf, hier kommt bestimmt gleich was. Einfach easy, easy,
easy. Einfach, einfach, einfach Ecke, wie ein CS. Komm mal, wir spielen, wir spielen
das jetzt wie CS. CS muss dir auch permanent werden, wenn du um die Ecken läufst. Irgendwie
gucken. Und im CS läuft das halt dann so um die Ecken. So. Ui. Die Maus funktioniert
ohne probleme also wenn man schon anfängt dummes zeug zu machen dann sieht man da sieht
man dass glaube ich mein team gerade ziemlich und so wann konnte man denn rausrennen überhaupt
jetzt schon jetzt ah nee wer hätte vorher rausrennen können auf drauf hier wo wo moment
wo war das noch mal wo man hoch konnte hier man konnte ja den also die pros sind ja außen
gelaufen nicht irgendwie da innen da innen rennen plus die nups und außen sind auch
die ersten die vom heli gebäst werden was alter der bender baba mann was ist denn mit was ist
denn mit dem dude los das ist original bellfield 3 ja oh das ist aber ein sehr soll ich sagen
sehr optimistisches spawn beacon sehr optimistisches spawn beacon äußerst optimistisches spawn
beacon ich würde das thema gar nicht unterstellen dass der hier krassen hackerstellz macht sein
crossing please die nächste also die base hier finde ich übrigens extrem schwer wenn
man einen guten heli mann hat dann geht es klar also wenn man denn den heli bekommt
weil ich mir gar nicht sicher bin die defender haben den heli spawn hier ne genau aber ansonsten
ist die base finde ich also wenn die gegner auch nur halb hallo halbwegs kompetenz sind
finde ich die base hier wirklich schwer ich muss ich muss glaube ich mal ach nee ich
war zu früh smoke smoke einpacken ach guck mal wir sind hier schon durch
die defender haben den heli den heli mann okay wir brauchen bisschen smoke
ja das flankieren ist halt auch so ein ding gegen den heli wenn du einen guten heli gegen
dich hast und die gegner halbwegs kompetenz spiel ist das hier also ist schon schwierig
warte mal wo war denn der kram jetzt hier noch mal da hier smoke die nächste base geht
dafür dann wieder eigentlich müssen wir den heli geiern irgendwie
drei leute mit stinger genau wir müssen eigentlich den heli bisschen geiern
ja super jetzt haben sie mich gespottet und können durchschießen gg spotting so und jetzt
nein man muss ja nicht hier rum guck mal man kann also wenn man gut ist und das geschickt
macht geht man darum problem ist dass da auch schon 20.000 gegner sitzen da machst du ja
nix da machst du nix ich wollte heli geier machen mit mit das stinger die base ist aber
auch finde ich echt eines der schwersten also es gibt es gibt aber noch härtere dinge beispielsweise
erste base send crossing im im im hof wisst ihr welche ich meine das da wenn viel gut
gg die base im hof dies krass die haben ein auto am start
ok kein schimmer was hier gerade abgeht aber smoke geht ab
jetzt man smoke all smoke pepega pepega smoke aber die gegner stellen sich halt halbwegs
kompetent an der kommst hier kaum durch das ist wirklich heftig aber wir sind wir sind
eigentlich ganz gut da ich meine auf der anderen seite brauchst halt einen guten push und es
oh wir sind dran
weggesprägt von hinten wir müssen es probieren du kannst im prinzip nur heli weg geiern und
smokeen was anderes kannst nicht wirklich machen ich gehe jetzt mal unter die heli geierer
ist doch eine drohne moment das geht seck ich ich wusste bis heute nicht dass man lull
das war mir nicht bewusst ja heli verpiss dich ich geier dich ab ich sags dir ich geier
dich weg ich geier dich sowas von weg heli komm komm da raus komm da raus heli ich geier
dich so weg jaja heli ich geier dich so hardcore weg jetzt sind sie am kotzen das mögen die
das mögen die nicht die heli spieler stinger ist so das das das ding schlechthin da wirst
auch immer geflammt im chat für dann wieso stink hat man auch wenigstweiter heli nervt
bei fett time was denn sonst und der heli quasi der hauptgrund war dass wir die base
fast nicht gekriegt haben easy das kaum ist der heli weg oder sagt man einer ich würde
nicht fürs team spielen ich meine ich habe mich hier sacrificed voll fürs team die runde
was ein satz wieder was ein bescheuertes hat ich habe mich sacrificed fürs team ja alles
klar habt ihr verstanden was ich meine war hier nicht war hier nicht irgendwie ein bilde
mir ein hier war eine medipack dann setzt sich auch in heli ich rieche der angepisster
heli pilot irgendwie so ein bisschen im chat gerade die battlefield drei soldaten sprüchen
sind halt auch so poc quit fucking around wir fucking nicht around wenn schon gatschi
passen wir ok ich dachte das jetzt in der eck wo wir sind wir sind wieder am start easy
guck mal hier kaum ist der heli weg bäm instant win wir sind auf dem dach hier jetzt habe
ich natürlich eine klasse ich glaube ich muss mal was auf was aufheben das ist jetzt
halt so ziemlich das blödeste was man haben kann für den tunnel aber wenn wir schnell
sind oder hat der hat die poc posi heute hier ist das ist die beste posi hinter dem truck
ok jetzt wieder was ordentliches rein spawnen hinterm truck ist halt richtig brutal op
oh the terminator geht ab monka die spaß headshot mit der spaß spaß headshot das muss
jetzt sein das immer leute das immer lege hänner am start ich sehe nix da kommt doch
klein was lege hänner nice rüber
the pants man oh kommst du her alter
oh misst gerade im falschen moment aufgestanden die slug money vermisse ich echt nicht slug
money vermisse ich nicht und ganz ehrlich das game ist nicht perfekt das muss man ja
auch echt mal sagen auch random suppression und manche sachen die bis heute verpackt sind
aber trotzdem jedes mal wenn ich das game spiele habe ich habe ich bock drauf ja das
ist einfach poggers das game
fack ich wollte außer line of sight laufen einfach massive poc haben wir die bae wir
haben die base easy to win easiest win würde ich fast schon sagen so die letzte base ist
noch ein bisschen schwieriger aber die schwerste haben wir die zweite ist die schwerste wo
man da über das offene feld laufen muss
aber guck mal das stripes ist am start pogu haben wir pogu überhaupt noch aktiviert im
chat pogu ist nicht mehr aktiviert leute jetzt haben wir verloren
pogu muss aktiviert sein
pogu im chat genau im ingame chat in battlefield ja da ist pogu mit sicherheit aktiviert
battlefield ingame chat pogu check please
aha kriegen wir den noch ja bleib da
manchmal weiß den battlefield 3 auch nicht so genau wo du wo du hin defi muss dass es
funkt ks alter ich habe ich habe ihn gesehen ich habe ihn gesehen vergesst das vergesst
die sind hartnäckig an der letzten base leute das habe ich gewusst dass du zurück kommst
das war mir so klar das mag ich auch an battlefield 3 das ist irgendwie das oh fuck man hier
sieht man alter man sieht ja gar nichts er dass man es irgendwie predicten kann was
die gegner machen das server ist gerade wieder heftig überlastet
die gegner also gegner und eigene leute klitschen schon klitschen schon durch den boden durch
wieder i get fucked up the ass over here sagt er
und weg pepega aimed aber letzte base also komm wenn wir die zweite base geschafft haben
müssen wir die letzte base eigentlich auch schaffen
die zweite ist viel schwerer wir packen mal wieder unser smoke ist einfach mvp wenn man
nicht durchkommt chat um übrigens guckt euch mal den chat oben an das ist doch gar nicht
so wild oder jetzt wird es mal wirklich klar wird da ein bisschen geflamed aber es ist
jetzt nicht so als wäre das so ultra toxik dass permanent die mutter beleidigt wird dass
du das ausschalten müsstest dann hier keine chance ok ich komme nicht hin
ich habe schiss leute ich habe richtig schiss keine ahnung wo hier gerade was abgeht ich
smoke ich nein ah wir haben gelegt das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen in der zwischenzeit
die lege henne easy clap so präge leute präge für zen crossing präge präge 30 sekunden
zeit für präge wenn genug wenn genug leute im chat prägen zentri senkos 64 präge wenn
senkos in durchsicht suchen wir uns einen anderen server das ist nicht level 25 das
ist kindle level 25 ach so meinst du das ja ach so ja das ist ja nicht hoch das stimmt
schon das ist auch nicht hoch kindle 25 das liegt daran weil der account tatsächlich
noch nicht so alt ist die mal ich habe ja die meisten ich habe ja die meisten spielstunden
ich habe keine ahnung 400 stunden auf der xbox oder so und ich habe smoke dabei fack
das war ziemlich dumm wo sind wir smoke defense 64 man ist ziemlich pepega moment war das
dieser dieser granat werfer granat werfer handgranaten werfer launcher dieses ding was niemand aber
auch wirklich absolut niemand spielt sehe ich das richtig ja was zum geier ist denn hier
los ok die haben uns ganz schön geschreckt jetzt würde ich mal sagen die haben uns ganz
schön gebumst am anfang alle hier machst du nix was zum acht der hat über meine klasse
genommen ey vergesst es 64 mit 64 kranpa sauber monac es da stirbt nix von please ich lebe
auch keine fünf sekunden hechte heftige monac erstellt hier aber jetzt endlich mal ordentliche
ordentliche waffe ich finde kranpa sauber defense die base ist ganz gut zu defend aber
die nächste finde ich richtig krass zu defend die nächste kommst du eigentlich kaum durch
wenn die eigentlich direkt am anfang überrennen und irgendwie noch was falsch läuft
holberg bliat bliat gekommnet alter was ist mit den duels los geht ja alles mit rechten
ding zu wenn der baba ist dauernd ich lasse dich nicht
retten was alle der captain peng anzeige ist raus man des modding des mod demod mit
der pumpe sind sie am start hier was haben wir denn was ich habe keine gadgets leute
ich habe ich habe keine gadgets irgendjemand spielt in der klasse komplett ohne gadgets
geht das überhaupt kann ich den hier aufheben jawoll noch
ein shotgun dude mann was ist mit den shotgun leuten los ich dachte mir vielleicht ja ja
ja ja ja ja please nicht retten fliegt noch lasst mich in ruhe lasst mich einfach liegen
ich will respawn ich lasse mich respawn please respawn lasst mich respawn ja da ist tx gg
jetzt halten wir die hier gerade kommt ein stückchen zurück ein stückchen also hier
muss man sich tatsächlich ein bisschen aufzupritten aber ich finde es ist einfacher mit die mitte
zu halten als die straße aber meistens ist es so dass auch mehr gegner die mitte pushen
also das heißt in dem sinn ich gehe ich gehe mal auf die andere seite und wenn die mitte
pushen dann hoffe ich dass ich es mitkriege okay hier ist von verloren eigentlich also
zumindest die die straße wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen an die ecke hier vorne ist immer
noch gut conquest ist tatsächlich ganz nice so erstmal schön spotten bitte was bitte
was shotgun slug headshot oder pence mann ist da der pence mann ist da leute
ich habe mich hier mal wie sieht es in der mitte aus in der mitte sterben auch ein paar
leute erstmal alles so pressen was geht da ist übrigens jetzt die top posi ich gehe
mal ich gehe mal in die mitte gucken was da so abgeht das ist mit ja nach der runde
nach der runde suche ich ein suchen wir uns einen neuen server nach der runde suchen wir
uns neuen server machen neuen server voll trost ich doch ich sehe nichts leute
wie ich einfach mal wusste dass da was ist ein nicer wallhack
alles klar alles klar obvios was hier gerade passiert komplett komplett logisch komplett
logisch überhaupt keine frage also chat ich glaube euch ist auch allen klar was gerade
passiert ist vollkommen easy durch zu blicken easy as fuck
der chat wenn die map in 64 mark ist kaputt ja stimmt schon das stimmt schon
vielleicht hätten wir was
blickste wirklich immer durch easy einfach einfach auf rote punkte einfach auf rote
punkte schießen so ist das top easy einfach rote punkte schießen beste posi am start
wieder einfach mit der m16 in eine richtung schießen das ist absolut high skill hier
das soll mir keiner was anderes sagen kann nicht jeder da musste schon da musste schon
das game mindestens 1000 stunden plus gespielt haben dass du das dass du das auf die reihe
kriegst achtung wir raschen da jetzt rein
die sind doch immer noch da hinten drin wusste ich doch klar wo die stellsten was die haben
gesetzt wie können die die lege hände hier machen gerade ihr könnt auch nicht einfach
lege hände hinter meinem rücken machen das glaube ich doch jetzt nicht das glaube ich
hat da waren die einfach lege hände
einfach hier sitzt so gerade ausschießen high skill gameplay leute hier richtig exzellent
high skill gameplay und dieser screen shake weggerotzt
jemand hier einfach doch einfach nur geradeaus einfach nur gerade aussprayen man einfach
nur gerade aussprayen da ist nix dabei guck mal da lebt wieder einer ich hab ich hab's
zucken sehen
das ist so der das ist so dumm high skill leute high skill cap haben wir's bald ich hoffe
wir haben's bald da sind noch welche da sind noch welche komm streck deinen kopf raus
jawoll also bei wo ich hab kein dieser kills wirklich irgendwie verdient ich schieße
im prinzip immer nur auf einen punkt geradeaus jetzt kommen die z4 jungs acht jetzt wird
gepusht push action pusherino nice wir müssen back gepusht haben gachi bus gachi bus weg
gepusht haben wir sie
ok das ist ein bug das sieht aus wie ein gegner ist aber kein gegner
man kann es ja mal probieren ok wir haben es gleich leute danach suchen wir uns ein 32
mann server und machen den voll weil auf basar attacker runde noch mal ne ne ne ne es reicht
es reicht
ja die map ist halt nix für 64 also 64 mann conquest geht eigentlich aber was halt überhaupt
nicht geht ist 64 mann rush
ach komm wir gucken mal was auf der anderen seite der map geht
irgendwas im hals stecken gachi gasm
ok leute wir suchen uns jetzt einen neuen server
ich bleib mal hier drinnen und mal gucken was es was es gibt refresh
also irgendwas was halt irgendwas mit gutem ping und was leer ist wir können auch einfach
auf den 64 mann conquest zeigt mal hier was haben wir denn für gute rush server
gibt nicht so viele leute empty empty
es gibt ja kaum rush server noch oder ist die suche verbackt
ja ja ich suche ja einen leeren
free for all
leute ich fürchte es gibt keinen server mehr auf dem wir spielen können
suchen wir mal suchen wir mal suchen wir mal suchen wir mal einen leeren conquest server
wo wir drauf können
ne venice kann ich nicht machen die meisten leute haben hier kein venice installiert
eu rusher
conquest large caspian borders no rules noob nein
die map rotations sucked
naja die map rotations ist jetzt anders so geil
pcgamer.com aber ich hab ein 15er ping auf den united states server
best hitrack alles klar
den 32er conquest ist blöd 32er rush gibt's keine
kann man hier suchen nach
game size 64 machen wir mal so
ok was was haben wir hier zu bieten ist viel viel ist es ja nicht hier den konnten wir
nehmen bf3 birthday 10 years of pc bf3 bazaar karkent firestorm das wellina meinetwegen
ok das ist das erscheint mir doch als ganz sinnige mischung
so eine mischung aus allem möglichen also hier bf3 birthday 10 years bf3 pc join
die dlcs hat glaub ich fast jeder
die waren ja nicht sogar kostenlos mit premium
das ist immer welche gibt die sie nicht haben
ok aber die meisten haben glaub ich die dlcs
aber das andere den anderen sinnigen server gibt's ja hier nicht
sonst hätte ich den anderen genommen danach noch mal gucken
so leute auf geht's
du weißt ja was das schlimme ist die straße hier die sieht detaillierter aus als strassen
in bf 2042 maps
ohm scheiß drauf m16
versucht das bf 7 zu m gehen aber das geht nicht richtig oder
funktioniert nicht wirklich
auf wahrscheinlich habe ich jetzt die ganzen ultra pros hier drauf
das hat ja keinen sinn in den lv zu rennen leute
in den lv rennen ist ziemlich ppega
ppega mich juckt seine nass
schnauze
wie gesagt macht ruhig den surfer voll, wenn wir den surfer nicht voll kriegen dann hat es ja keinen sinn dass ich jetzt auf einen leeren surfer gegangen bin
Was mit dem los
Wie heißt der surfer, dass der hier
Bf3 birthday 10 years of bf3 pc
Ja alles klar genau bf3 bf3 10 years of bf3 pc
easy eats eats eats eats eats
Moment ich will immer noch rutschen
Dabei ist rutschen ja nichts mehr hier in oder war rutschen noch nichts in bf3 was ich eigentlich auch ganz gut finde ich finde dieses hüppen fast besser als das rutschen
Das rutschen ist so wir wollen krampf auf warzone sein
Ich weiß dass das rutschen auch in bf5 gab
Aber trotzdem
Was ist da vorne los
Ich sehe gerade geschnass aber es füllt sich langsam
Ja ja gut Kollege ist gut Kollege alles klar alles klar
Eigentlich wollte ich mal hier hochstelzen siehste das dachte ich mir zum Glück und zum Glück hat er mich nicht getroffen richtig
Oh wie er das wusste alter
Gab es das rutschen nicht schon in bf1 das ist eine gute frage
Ich weiß nicht ich habe bf1 so gut wie nicht gespielt
Ich weiß nicht ob man das schon rutschen konnte konnte man chat das müsst ihr wissen konnte man schon rutschen in bf1
Lass den rutschstelz machen
Jetzt haben wir es geben
Was ist denn hier los
Soll man nicht voll kriegen dann suche ich mir was anderes weil es ist halt doof mein acht vs acht muss muss nicht sein
Was ist mit euch los warum wird hier gang bang von beiden seiten gemacht
Hinten gemacht
Oh, von hinten, fuck, in the bobs.
Nee Leute, ich glaub das kriegen wir nicht voll.
Das kriegen wir glaube ich nicht voll.
Ja es gibt leider keinen anderen Surfer.
Wobei ich finde er hat eine coole Map-Rotation, ja wenn ihr keine DLCs habt geht das nicht.
Aber es gibt auch keinen anderen Surfer, das ist das Problem.
Was wir haben deren LLV, easy, denn ich will meinen Flank aussparen können.
Nee, ich würde die DLCs jetzt nicht kaufen für so ein altes Game.
Nee, es gibt keinen anderen Surfer Leute, es gibt keinen anderen Surfer.
Wir haben die, wir haben volle Surfer, aber wir haben keinen leeren Surfer wo man nicht
die DLCs braucht.
Meine Lieblings Posi Leute, beste, beste Posi hier, beste Posi, guck her da sind sie
schon.
Habt ihr den gesehen?
Ich nicht.
Ich hab einfach nur random in die Richtung geschossen weil ich gedacht hab ich hab was
gesehen, aber anscheinend war das echt.
Okay wir müssen das, wir müssen das protekten.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, ah es füllt sich, es füllt sich, es füllt sich.
Oder wenn die Leute heute wieder Hardcore getriggert gewesen hätten, dann hätten die
das in Battlefield 2042 gesagt.
Oh shit, ich dachte ich komm noch um die Ecke, nee den hab ich auch gesehen, Caspian Border
Only war das Ding, nee, nee nicht Caspian, es waren zwei Maps, Caspian Border und noch
irgendwas, das ist aber auch dumm, das will ich auch nicht in der Dauerrotation spielen.
Wow, hoho, FJ hast du nicht mit uns letzten Stings gespielt, Battlefield 2042, der Name
kommt mir bekannt vor.
Warst du nicht der der mit der AK-24 da so abgegangen ist, doch ich glaub ja, doch, doch
ich erinnere mich, ich erinnere mich, so mal gucken wie es ausschaut, wird das noch irgendwie
voll kriegen hier?
Eigentlich hat es ja auch keinen Sinn sich immer da um die Mitte zu kloppen.
Muss mal die anderen Dinge auch Captchern.
Battlefield please, auf Captchern, gib ihm, nice, ok hier vorne wird gebashed, mal außen
rumflanken, a 10 10, schau ma mal, oh gatchi bus, Leute gatchi bus, gatchi bus, gatchi bus,
gatchi bus, gatchi bus, gatchi bus, gatchi bus, oh fuck,icher hast probiert, oh nice res.
ich glaube es nicht sitzen immer noch da sind wir noch 10 10
die leben doch noch
Ah, guck mal, schon wieder noch mehr Spieler.
Ich hoffe wir kriegen das Ding voll.
Ich hab ein Problem, ich hab keine Muni mehr.
Das kommt äußerst selten vor eigentlich in dem Game.
Das kommt wirklich nicht oft vor.
Kann einer droppen?
Nee, ich glaub wir haben gar keinen mit Munistells am Start.
Ah gut, gehen wir mal hier runter.
Ohne 3D-Spotting wäre man lost, ja.
Aber ich finde es trotzdem, auch wenn das OP erst fuck ist mit dem 3D-Spotting, finde
ich trotzdem besser als dieses komische Motion-Sensor gespottet.
In Battlefield 2049 bist du entweder quasi permanent gespottet und weißt es nicht so
richtig.
Oder bist du aus anderen Gründen Gachibust um die Ecke?
Okay der hat's nicht so.
Fuck.
Ich dachte ich kann den Jumpshot irgendwie um die Ecke.
Was ist Gachibust, gib es doch mal ein im Chat.
Ja das ist eines meiner Standard-Emotes.
Gachibust.
Ey Leute, wo ist denn die Rex?
Bin ich blöd, wo ist denn die?
Hab ich die nicht?
Kann das sein, dass ich die nicht hab?
Wo hab ich die nicht?
Ist das die Co-Op Waffe, oh nein, ich hab wirklich auf dem Account keine Co-Op.
Na gut, okay Chat ihr wisst was demnächst ansteht, wir müssen Co-Op spielen.
Opfert sich einer mit mir Co-Op.
Joa, ging das voll, also sag mal so die Hälfte, knapp die Hälfte des Servers ist voll.
Aber wir sind schon aufgerundet ja.
Null Dankeschön OpM16, KeckWade.
Op tut es schnicks, woa, woa, woa, okay, okay, das ist natürlich doof, über Bande.
Oh shit, oh oh, oh von hinten.
Oh fuck, kommt sich ja vor wie ein CS hier beim
eckigen Ab-Aim.
Der Rest.
Alter Schneiber, man das war nix.
Ey das Ding ist schon krass, Op, oh der hat uns weggesprayt, der Buschwuggy.
G3A3, ich hab hier auf dem Account auch nicht alles unlockt.
Okay, beweg dich, 11, 11, also egal wir spielen das jetzt einfach, vielleicht kriegen wir
das hier, Captain Poggers, Massive Poggers Driving.
Ah das hast du dir so gedacht.
Hallo.
Massive Skillwaffen, Skillwaffen only heute.
Ihr sehts, heute ist nur ein 94, Scar, Sniper, G3, ihr seht heute keine Lowskillwaffen wie
M16.
Ausgeschlossen heute, only wins und only highskill, wie man gerade gesehen hat.
Mit der Magnum, oh und der ASC, der ASC shootet.
Pray, dass wir den Server vollkriegen, so ne richtig fette 64m Conquest Runde mit allen
aus dem Chat wär schon echt ziemlicher Pog.
Ziemlicher Pog, Pogge wär das, Pogge.
Oh fuck, ich hab mich reloaded.
Der ist doch noch da hinten drinnen, oder?
Da stellts doch einer von euch hier, nö.
Hab nix gesagt, ok die Leute lieven schon wieder, das wär doch nix mit vollem Server,
das ist nicht VU, ne ich hab extra nicht VU gestartet, weil ich mir gedacht hab es ist
einfacher hier Leute zu finden.
No Pass, aber es könnten jetzt ja auch mal langsam Leute außen, ja klar M16, ne heute
ist nicht M16, weiß gar nicht wo du M16 siehst, ich seh hier keine, ah von hinten, ich seh
hier keine M16.
Wie heißt der Server, achja Leute hier, bf3 birthday 10 years of bf3 pc, Link im Chat,
ne, mein copy paste funktioniert nicht, mein copy paste klappt nicht, 1, mein copy paste
ist broken, af, oh, ja der hier aber, also wenn wir das nicht voll kriegen, in 10 minuten
suche ich mir noch für die restlichen abends was anderes, also um 20 nach, also was heißt
voll.
Sagen wir mal nennenswert, hallo spring, spring, nennenswert, nennenswert gefüllt.
Sagen wir mal 30, 40 plus Leute, ich hab ihn immer gesehen.
Oh oh, da kommt ein Auto, das ist ziemlich, ziemlich pain's jam, ne das bekomm man Leute,
den kriegen wir nicht voll, den kriegen wir nicht voll, das hat keinen Sinn, feels Batman,
feels zu wenig Leute, seriously, seriously, die sind hinter uns gespawnt, lul, nice gg,
na jetzt sind wieder ein paar gejohnt.
Alter die farmen sich hier ein ab.
Oh das war meine eigene, keck wait, ne wir kriegen das nicht voll, das sackt doch, was
können wir denn sonst, hat jemand noch ne gute serveridee Leute, irgendwas, weil noch
mal 64 man conquest, äh nicht 64 man conquest, äh noch mal 64 man irgendwie bazaar oder
so hab ich kein bock drauf, und auf 64 man metro hält sich mein bock auch hinkränzen
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
64 man metro ist nicht so enjoyer modus, was sind die alle down, spawnen bestimmt jetzt
auch werder.
haben wir es bald
haben wir es haben wir es bald
haben wir es heute haben wir es heute noch mal
ja die sollen die dlc einfach mal kostenlos verteilen ich meine allen ernst
dass das game ist zehn jahre alt wer sich jetzt die dlc nicht gekauft hat
jetzt die dlc auch nicht mehr kaufen oder ist das auto
das ist dumm ich suche mir da ich suche jetzt einen anderen zauber wir sind wir
quasi seit eine viertel stunde die kleinen spieleranzahl ja ich suche jetzt
anderen zu aber was sehen wir denn jetzt zeig doch mal ja
alles ich nehme alles leute
es gibt kein zauber mit dem base game das ist ja das problem dann hätte ich
den ja genommen gibt es nicht es gab keinen 64 mann konquest aber mit dem
base game mit einer guten rotation und der lever ich glaube das kriegst ja nicht
so viele leute drauf also was schnappen was sehen wir jetzt
noch mal für die letzten paar runden also eher legends auf jeden fall nicht
metro only auch nicht
konquest large markas molin ich die map finde ich jetzt nicht so geil
warum gibt es da eigentlich eigentlich surfer was nix was nix anderes hat mit
mit der rotation
ich habe es doch probiert den selber zu füllen ging nicht
eierstorm habe ich auch keinen bock drauf
es gibt ja nix
es gibt nichts was wir spielen könnten
aber noch einen haben wir noch einen 32 rush
vielleicht
bier und rush aber das ist das ist in kokona so aber da hab ich einen scheiß ping
drauf dem aber wenn pg metro abwechseln ich gucke mal kurz wieder mein ping ist
wenn ich drauf bin
backbattlefield 3 ich habe heute die auswahl zwischen
battlefield 20 42 und battlefield 3 habe ich so gedacht weißt du was wir spielen
wir wieder eine runde battlefield 3
ob ich den ordentlichen ping habe aber ich finde keinen gescheiten surfer den
ich spielen will ziemlich sagt 115 ping ja ganz bestimmt
ganz bestimmt ganz bestimmt
ja leute es bleibt uns wohl nichts anderes übrig als diesen müll zu
spielen von wegen 64 mann rush
was haben die für eine rotation armord schild banda desert halbos mal acht du
große kakel was ist denn das ist der schake die einzig geizig gute map
ja 20 42 kannst du voll knicken
es gibt nix
chat es gibt nichts konquest large eine map
den hier vielleicht
wobei das halt krass an balance ist den surfer kenn ich da habe ich öfters mal
drauf gespielt das ist halt wirklich ziemlich pp gar egal wir gehen jetzt
drauf was anderes bleibt uns nicht übrig reconnect gogo was anderes bleibt uns
nicht übrig ich will jetzt noch ein zwei runden spielen was wahrscheinlich eine
runde noch dann ist gut
selber hosten das dumme ist battlefield 3 surfer
selber hosten das ist nicht mal gemacht mit wir klicken zwei dreimal bei einem
host da du musst da schon ein bisschen gedanken zu machen also ich meine es
nicht nur zu rotation und so was du brauchst ja auch ein paar plugins du
brauchst die plugins für bands du brauchst vielleicht noch sniper limit und
sowas das ist dass das da bist du schon mal sagen halb tag mit beschäftigt und
das lohnt sich im endeffekt auch nicht weil das hat jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig
viele kommen sehr balanced sehr balanced wo wir hier drauf sind megabalanced
huge balanced
oh oh in den kopf
wir sind wir haben ja sogar tatsächlich basar konkurs 64 man na dann schauen wir
mal dann wollen wir mal
was haben wir eigentlich für den perk set up
haben wir irgendwas okay das natürlich ziemlich pepega eigentlich aber ok
liegen sie drin wollte gerade sagen warum warum sie wieder durchgerannt ja
vu ist der leider leider muss man sagen ist vor der die haben es selbst ein
bisschen mit verkackt an sich von technischer seite her kann ich echt
nichts negatives sagen also für das dass es ein mod ist dass es ein fan
projekt ist wirklich wirklich an sich richtig gut
das problem ist nur die hatten halt so komische community so was die fast
alle gesagt haben oder teilweise die admins sogar den sheets ausgepackt haben
wenn es schlecht lief oder habe ich mal gedacht das kann es ja nur wirklich
nicht sein von ks also und auch komische regeln teilweise die hätten wenn es
ein offiziellen server machen müssen das offiziellen server in wenn es mit
guten rules die nicht so weit von vanilla weg sind
all das oppression ist ja gut mensch ich habe so ein problem ich komme nicht
weg weggespray der chat guck mal der chat wieder richtig toxic toxic chat jetzt
wisst ihr auch warum sie den abgeschalten an den battlefield 2242
die haben ihn abgeschaltet weil sie über wie soll ich sagen so so auf
operative sein wollen das tante brunhilde sich nicht auf den schlips
getreten fühlt wo es wollen wir denn jetzt rein ja b was anderes gibt es ja
gerade nicht und suppression wie gesagt suppression war auch eines der coolen
sachen diese in wenn es abgeschaltet haben beziehungsweise runter drehen
konnten und alles alter was clusterfuck wieder ich komme nicht mal so
pressen irgendwie raus nicht gegen den toter bei mir um so aus oder ist
schlecht monka es
oh ich seh mich nicht ihr seht mir nicht leute da hier ist keine granate keine
granate erst mal in kopf
alle wie schnell ist der unterwegs
das ist doch mal kacke also da müssen wir woanders da das müssen wir anders
anders angehen komme ich ob ich hier rauskomme noch mal
ich vermute ja mal nicht glaube ich kann ich einfach nur abkämpfen und hoffen
dass ich irgendwann sterbe ja easy easy komme ich hier raus ok easy
guckt euch an zack raus ja bämpf
oh god was ein klasse fahrer aha wir machen hätte klitschen
naja naja ist er hätte klitsch oh jetzt so weg da oben
monial lasst mich please liegen lasst mich liegen lasst ich will woanders
spawn ja ja lasst mich liegen lasst mich liegen ach so fps render draw f was render
draw fps 1 denk mal so 180 oder so ok eh nee andere seite hätten wir gemusst
war flank action was machen die denn da da kommt nichts leute da kommt nichts
unsere leute sitzen gerade im gang
gachi base
also ich kann auch nicht mehr als 200 haben hier ist natürlich doof jetzt sind
die leute schon am start hier
oh f 2000 ok vielleicht hätte ich doch mal b bleiben sollen
die anderen seite ok wo ist hier was vielleicht haben wir glück und kommen
rüber safe safe nice rüber vielleicht haben wir nämlich glück oder kommt was
achtung das waren zwei ja 200 fps wie gesagt ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man
mehr anlocken kann als 200 fps in battlefield 3 keine ahnung
wov nice gg jetzt was ist im chat
gekommnet im chat gekommnet am start
oh nee jetzt verlieren wir wieder alles ich glaube jetzt müssen wir doch b rein
keine andere chance außer klasse da fack
das da fack deluxe
alles klar ob wir ist was hier passiert also wer hier nicht durchblick sollte
lieber an install easy easy easy ist durchblick of my life hier
ach hier geht die wand kaputt das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht das war mir gar
nicht bewusst dass sie die wand kaputt gehen kann
meine güde was ein klasse fack keine explosiv limit ja feifein time was
also wie ich habe doch wieder gelegen das ist ich glaube das server ist kann
ein bisschen am ab verbrennen
ok
böser strike wir sollten aber ehrlich gesagt lieber squad cover nehmen
besser was zum teufel ist mit den leuten los
vielleicht können wir flanken da kommen noch mehr klein und da kommen noch mehr
pass mal auf okay der muss im prinzip nur gerade aus
mir das kannst du nicht kontesten das kannst du nicht kontesten gescheit hier
geradeaus keine chance der muss einfach nur geradeaus zielen
hier unten ist einer drin
können vielleicht außen rum ich habe keinen bock hier auf die ganze
zeit in diesem gang rum zu rennen ist ziemlich low iq und durch eure ganzen
prime prime subs habe ich so hohen iq da kann ich nicht so diese diese low iq
spielweise machen
kann ich mal sterben
90 90 prozent im gang ja das kann auch andere was stecken hier was
sind das das steckt was drin
ihr trifft mich nicht easy ihr trefft mir nicht leute easy ihr könnt mich gar
nicht treffen wenn sich jetzt uns bewegen würde
nein nein lasst mich
Nein!
Lass mich!
Geh weg!
Weg!
Ach ja stimmt, es gibt ja den 64-Player-Mode, den wollte ich eigentlich ausprobieren.
Alter, hier kannst du nicht raus, vielleicht hab ich Glück, jetzt, jawoll, ok, ok, nice.
Ok, ok, ok, nein, nein, nein, nein, ah, Alter, es ist ja, du konntest ja nirgendswo hin,
du kannst so wirklich nirgendswo hin, ich hab's jetzt ja echt probiert mal außenrum
zu kommen.
Im Prinzip bleibt der ja echt nur Gangstels hier, einfach, einfach Gangstels, ja, Gangstels,
was willst du machen?
Die haben auch noch nen Jeep auf der anderen Seite stehen und Mörser, und Mörser noch
am Start.
Ja ne, das klappt nicht, ok, wir flanken, wir gehen andersrum, andersrum, wir gehen
so rum, nicht hier, sondern so rum, warum liegen da welche, einfach random mitten auf
der Map, liegen irgendwelche Typen auf der Erde, Gangway, was ist jetzt mit euch los,
Gangstelstels, ja, Corona kickt wieder, Leute, Februar wird Boosterstels gemacht.
Wenn wir hier rausgehen sind wir Deadge, ich sag euch wie es ist, Instant Deadge, richtig
Deadge, da fährt sogar ein Panzer rum auf der anderen Seite, Alter, es gibt ja keine
Ecke wo du raus kannst gerade, ok, YOLO, YOLO, YOLO, was zum, was, achja, ich hab
einen, ach da, Alter, BTF, was ist mit euch los, ich bin einfach in der Ecke rumgammelt,
oh, was haben wir denn hier, Aswall ohne Extended Mac, he is Batman, kann ja nichts werden, ja,
wir probieren das mal die Tage aus, Leute, wir probieren die Tage 2042 wieder aus mit
64 Mann, ein anderes Squad oder so vielleicht, wo die, wo die high IQ Leute drin sind, als
guter Spieler haben wir nur den Bushwookie gerade, ey, das ist mir zu Pains Champ gerade,
aber habt ihr es gesehen Leute, man kann Squad wechseln, ist euch das aufgefallen, habt ihr
es gemerkt, was für krasse High End Funktionen hier in dem Spiel auf einmal drin sind, also
da muss, die haben echt bestimmt so ein Pakt mit dem Teufel eingegangen in Schweden damals,
das geht das nicht, ja, natürlich, der stirbt davon nicht, was, ein Mörser, ne, das macht
gerade auch keinen Bock, macht auch nicht wirklich Bock gerade, gibt's, game not starting, ja,
schön, gerade kein gescheiten Server, den wir spielen können, ein gescheiten Server,
aber er ist dumm, 32 Mann Rush, das Problem ist, die Server, diese Cloverfield Server
sind halt mega krass unbalanced, meistens dominatet da eine Seite, heftig, wieso, was
ist bei der Steam Version so schlecht, achso, ja, ich weiß, was du meinst, dass die Steam
Version keine Steam Version ist, dass die Steam Version quasi einfach Origin startet,
ja, das ist richtig dumm, ne, Markas Monolith bin ich jetzt nicht so scharf drauf, Leute,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was spielen soll, kein Schimmer, Leute, ich weiß es nicht, ich glaube,
ich lass es jetzt gut sein, gibt ja nix, was ist, vielleicht ist, pass auf mal auf, vielleicht
ist der andere Server jetzt wieder voll, ne, der hat Null, ja, BattleLock ist auch Hexenwerk,
Leute, wir sehen uns nicht die Office, gibt nix was, ich gibt keine gescheiten Server
gerade und alles andere, was es gibt, hab ich keinen Bock richtig drauf, da waren die 64 Mann
Rush-Dinger tatsächlich noch am besten, bis denn Leute, wir sehen uns, machts gut, CU.